Every Burger?
The Hell is this?
The tiniest cheeseburger I've ever seen.
Like a burger filled with chocolate. I mean, nothing's wrong with that.
Oh my God, What?
There's even cheese!
It has like a sesame seed bun.
I think there are actual sesame seed on this.
I wish this was a cereal, though. Honestly.
Oh, it actually says how to open.
There's some instructions here but, I don't like to follow instructions.
"Attach the plunger", is this the plunger?
Ow!
So maybe we'll look at the instructions.
Press down firmly with the base of your palm to release the marble... *Laughing*
Ew look at the marble! This is probably what babies look like before they come out.
If you're thirsty, don't get this drink.
It went in!
Mmm Hmmm!
That's not bad. I mean it does taste like a dentist office.
But I like the ball.
I like shrimp, I like chips, but combining them?
Oh... *Laughing*
It's like, "Ahhhh, lots of shrimp!"
Ah, man.
It's like if you misted french fries with shrimp.
But I kind of like it.
They're super good!
Cream Collon, they look like beautiful little cream puffs.
Collon's just what I want in a snack.
That's a good name for a cookie.
It looks like combos but like a sweet combo.
It smells of yogurt.
Yes, yes cream collon.
Ok I'm guessing it's their version of beef jerky.
They look like dreadlocks.
This is a worm, right?
I like this.
It sort of tastes like a fish-burp.
As I chewing it, I like it less and less.
I would eat this squid-jerky.
It's actually really good.
At this point I don't like it at all anymore.
Ah, we're gonna, we're gonna take some water here.